okay speaking of uh fantastic now we're
gonna go to our daily cancellation
um and for our daily cancellation today
i'm afraid that i
i have to cancel tommy laron now i used
to work with tommy full disclosure we
were both over at the blaze
for a while i mean we were different we
were in different states so it's not
like we collaborated closely together
but i went on a show a few times and it
was great
um and so this cancellation is nothing
personal
but it must be done because nobody
escapes the wrathful gaze
of the daily cancellation you know that
by now even my wife and kids don't
nobody no mortal even immortals
okay they aren't necessarily off the
hook either so tommy is cancelled for a
lengthy psa that she
she published yesterday a 14 minute
minute video criticizing men
talking about why men are terrible and
why her own relationship problems are
the fault
of men and men are as she said trash
take a listen these women range
in every body type and every everything
they're all successful
they're all intelligent they're all good
people but if all of these women
including myself are having issues then
i have to think
it might not be us it might be you it
might be men
it might be men now i've often talked
about the pussification of america
and how men are no longer men i talked
to my mom about this a lot and she says
well maybe it's just the guys in texas
maybe it's just the guys in los angeles
it is not just the guys in los angeles
nashville dallas and it's not they're
not any better in the midwest they quite
frankly i think they're trash all over
this country
in the age range of about 20 to i think
about
55 maybe even 60. a lot of men are trash
a lot of men don't know how to treat
women a lot of men don't know how to
really
quite frankly pull their heads out of
the sand and pay attention so i
am going to help you tommy also said
reading now from
amanda preston giacomo's daily wire
article about it she also said i'm not a
feminist so please don't take this as a
feminist rant
laryn interjected after imploring men to
follow up with plans instead of merely
texting women
i love men i think men are great i think
men have failed themselves and they
failed us
and i'm trying to help you out because i
love men i think they're great they're
just failures that's all
they're great but they're failures
that's all i'm trying to tell you
they're great failures they're great at
failing anyway um
she says and i'm just trying to help you
out because i think there are a lot of
really great guys out there who need a
little help
and i don't think there are a lot of
women uh that are stepping up and saying
these things
this isn't patronizing at all is it i
think you're fantastic i just think you
need a little help that's all you need
help from me
a 27 year old blonde woman
so uh continuing she says so i'm going
to go ahead and say them because
they need to be said i am really so sick
of my friends having to deal with trash
men i'm tired of dealing with trash men
the pundit also told men to value value
and not quote mix in people like me and
my friends
who have something going on with your
other girls that have nothing going on
don't mix us in with the
is that a is that a what is that
t-h-o-t-i-n-a-s
is that a thing the kids are saying now
i don't know what that means
don't mix us in with the thought
thotianas
anyway um and then she goes on from
there okay
now it goes without saying that
if a man were to ever make a video
claiming that most women between the
ages of 20 and 60 are
trash it would be roundly condemned as
insanely sexist and he would be written
off as a bitter lonely virginal incel
that that's what would happen we all
know that
um women have a a better chance of
getting away with something like this
now
at least the consequences aren't as
severe tommy is sustaining quite a bit
of criticism for this and rightly so but
it's not the same
as it would be if her name was you know
thomas or her name was spelled
t-o-o-m-m-y instead of with an i
uh it'd be a totally different ballgame
but we all know that now yes it's true
that men
have issues in this culture it's true
that that men
many men are not living up to their
calling as men
are not fulfilling their masculine
duties it's true that that some men are
soft and pathetic
and rather wimpy it's true that some men
would rather lay around the house all
day playing video games than actually go
out and live a real
active assertive life all of that is
true
and you could argue that all tommy was
doing was pointing these things out but
there are two problems
number one first problem is this
we get it okay we really do
we all know this stuff about men we've
heard it a million times
men are lectured constantly everywhere
by
everyone always men are lectured at in
school
at work in in their homes
on tv at church you'll notice speaking
of church
um and i'm i'm certainly not the first
person to have noticed this that
mother's day sermons at church are
usually about how wonderful and amazing
and un
appreciated mothers are while father's
day sermons at churches
are often focused on how men need to
step up and do a better job
okay and that's the dynamic in the
culture that we get
so we get it we've heard it that doesn't
mean we never need to hear it again
or that it never needs to be said again
but it does mean that if all you have to
offer
is the same old tired lecture with not
any
without any you know additional insight
um
with with nothing unique to to add into
it then then just don't bother save your
breath
save your energy because once again
we've heard it we know we get it
i promise you number two
women are not innocent in this they are
they aren't even
more innocent than men it's more than
just oh women
have faults too notes women are just as
bad
they're just as guilty they're just as
culpable okay
you want gender equality right well here
it is enjoy
gender equality means that if there's a
problem in
you know in relations between men and
women you don't get to just assume that
it's all a man's fault
because when you do that what you're
essentially saying is that
you know this is all entirely up to the
men to the man
i mean he has the lead and uh and you
know he's in charge and so if things go
sideways it's going to be his fault
that's the only way the only way you
could put all the blame on men
is by saying that men are totally in
charge and should be
and so that whenever things don't work
out it's going to be their fault but
something tells me that that's not
tommy's perspective
um something tells me that
tommy is not someone who would say that
women should always be submitting to the
leadership of men
it could be wrong but i'm guessing
that's not her position
if it's not your position then you don't
get to put all the blame on men or even
most of the blame on men
or even 51 of the blame women it is 50
50.
because guess what i know you want to
talk about anecdotal evidence here
i know plenty of great guys who've had
trouble finding um
women trouble finding women who are not
to use tommy's phrase trash and
do you know why they've had trouble well
because in some cases they don't make a
lot of money
or you know they've got you know they're
employed they
they they have good jobs they just they
don't make tons of money
or you know maybe they don't necessarily
look like calvin klein models
but they're good men hard-working men
loyal intelligent all of that
sometimes i know men like this i think
we all do
they've had trouble finding a woman
because in their experience
women will find superficial and
materialistic reasons to turn away men
who definitely
are not in any way trash so this is a
knife that cup cuts both ways and here's
the thing
if you're having trouble finding a match
for you
and if you find that everyone you come
across is trash
and that there's a fatal flaw with every
member of the opposite sex that you've
ever encountered
then yes it could be that you have
horrible luck it could be
woe is you you're a victim uh this is
all everybody else's fault and not your
own that's possible
you could keep keep getting stuck with
duds through no fault of your own you
could keep reaching your hand into the
barrel of apples and taking out a rotten
one by accident
maybe sure but it's quite possible and i
would say even likely and
in fact quite probable that the problem
is at least
partially you it's
it's quite likely that some of those men
who you dismissed as trash
actually aren't trash but you toss them
aside as trash
because they fail to meet your
expectations in some
relatively unimportant area you might
even say you tossed them aside as
trash for trashy reasons
it's quite possible that many of the of
the trashmen actually are trash but
there's something about you and your
personality
that attracts those kinds of people
those are all possibilities too
and so if i was in this spot
and which i'm not and believe me here's
the other here's the other stipulation
i'll make is that anyone who's single
man or woman
in in this culture god be with you
uh i i have nothing but sympathy for you
and i thank god every day that i'm not
okay i couldn't be happier to be married
so um but even so
if if i was in that spot
and i found that uh you know i'm looking
for a woman but
every woman i meet is is
horrible and selfish and materialistic
and uh bimbo and all this stuff
then i'm gonna start to think to myself
you know i i i think there's gonna be a
moment where i really stop and i think
what am i doing wrong here
maybe everyone else is doing something
wrong it's possible
but then it's weird because i look
around and i see that there
are plenty of people who manage to find
other good people and they have good
relationships
that does exist there are plenty of
married people in this country even
young married people who have good
marriages
that does exist it's it's not it's it's
not a it's not a myth
it's not an urban legend it exists i'm
telling you i can tell you from an
experience that exists
so i think i would look at that and i
would say hmm
okay so it is possible to find a good
person
plenty of other people have done it
and yet i can't why is that
i could be a victim of the universe yeah
that's true the universe is picking on
me
i don't know maybe jeez maybe there's
something about me that just attracts
these types
am i am i attractive to horrible people
or or or do i
am i someone who doesn't even can't even
identify a good virtuous person because
i'm so lacking in virtue myself
and so i have possibly thrown out a lot
of virtuous people
because i didn't recognize them for the
virtues they had i mean so these these
are all these are these are this is a
self analysis that i would
undergo and i guess that would be my
here's my psa that i'm going to throw
out there to
not just women men and women you know if
you're having problems in this regard
rather than blaming everybody else and
giving tips and advice
to other people by the way i always love
it when when
people who have not had a successful
relationship
give relationship advice okay that's
like
if you're training someone
on a on a how to fly but every plane
that you've ever piloted has crashed
it's like if i'm a rookie pilot looking
for some advice i'm probably not going
to go to you
but in any case um rather than going and
giving advice and all of that
and blaming everyone maybe do a little
bit of a self analysis
and the speech and lecture you want to
give
maybe go into your bathroom and give
that lecture into the mirror
because i think that's probably the
number one person that needs to hear it
and uh for that reason tommy larrin is
cancelled
hey you uh yeah you you're right you
right there
hit the subscribe button right now do it
do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it's
somewhat appreciated